[Music]
you were in Australia you come to United
States what's the biggest cultural
difference that that you notice right
away you know I've spent probably half
of my life in the United States and I
grew up half of my life in Australia so
the cult there are many cultural
differences I'd say that the most
predominant one that I recognised on a
consistent basis and is the most
difficult for me to kind of adapt to is
the wearing of swimwear really you guys
don't wear swimwear in Oslo yeah in
sweat in in Australia we're born with
speedos on you ladders you come out of
the womb predominantly pretty much with
a speedo on that's many really
impossible and disgust
there are your younger years you know
you go to pool parties you got out of
the beach all that kind of stuff
everyone wears speedo gentlemen wear
speedos the older you get into you're
you know probably 60s and 70s that means
you wear speedo everywhere you go it
doesn't matter if it's a wedding or a
party you're always a guy is in a casket
in a speedo I mean that's just that
blows my mind
ABB's and it's a good look and then
obviously in America it's broad short
sport shorts and and and and and that's
pretty much it and I I'll tell you a
quick funny story my first experience
coming to the United States I was in a
[ __ ] in Miami and we were working there
and there was a this Texas businessman
we were all decided to go down at the
out of the beach after work and
everybody kind of stripped off their
retire and and I obviously stripped down
in my speedo I think I was about 18
years old this Texan guy turned around
and looked at me and he was in his heavy
weighted board shorts you know down to
here
yeah he was about six foot five and
quite intimidating mm-hmm and the look
that he gave me was so disturbing so
absolutely shocking and horrified it was
like I was naked basically I was like I
think he was in love
it sounds like to me is he was like
[Applause]
going going going I mean that's what I'm
getting from this story is that he was
very much sensually attracted to you
I'm gonna take that actually I'm gonna
change my story a little bit yeah he did
he did say in his very text and drawly
what the hell you think you wearing
there buddy boy because I'd like to get
me that you don't first of all I thank
God I like The Hobbit a hobbit
yeah that's what Texas do that's what um
I really like the board shorts the board
shorts saved my life I'm glad you're sad
you know I was gonna ask you this do you
God I go awarness pedo know you'll never
there's no I've never worn a speedo and
you don't wear a speedo
Andy's no no I was when I was younger I
and in international waters I would when
I was younger
what's your speedo you'll have to check
out my website
now what I used to because I I hate
boardshorts it's like swimming in pants
yeah like once you get in the water it's
like you you might as well be I like
anything that covers the most of me yeah
I would if I could by today and I'm
throwing this challenge out there if
there's a place where I can buy a 1920's
style bathing suit bit goes you know the
kind where people are as I have a
there's straw hat and like well go to
all the ocean gamma-d yeah if I could
get that bathing suit I would buy it and
wear it every time I went to the beach
cuz and everyone ya know what no I just
I don't it's not it
I'm going to the beach I'm not going to
wear much and that's not really my
problem
[Applause]
you